[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning tony
decouple reveals new details about an
epic treasure hunt
in tomorrow night's 48 hours millionaire
forest fenn announced back in 2010
that he hit about one million dollars
worth of gold in the rocky mountains
tens of thousands of people search for
the jackpot over the next decade
now tony has covered this treasure hunt
from the very beginning and was
instrumental in bringing it to a
national audience here's part of his 48
hours report
i think forest wanted to become a legend
and i actually think he succeeded
he was described as a modern-day indiana
jones
sasha dent remembers being captivated
the very first time she heard
of forrest fenn a santa fe millionaire
and former art gallery owner
forrest came up with the idea to hide a
bronze
chest filled with gold somewhere in the
rocky mountains
estimated worth one million dollars
i thought it was the coolest thing i'd
ever heard sasha was
all in i really think the greatest thing
that drove me
was wanting to match wits with the man
himself
and matching wits meant deciphering a
cryptic poem
he wrote a 24 line poem
guiding people to the location of the
treasure
yeah that's exactly it he created
effectively a treasure map in the form
of that poem
dan barbarese tried searching for the
treasure he didn't find it
but he had better luck writing about the
fenn phenomena for his new book
chasing the thrill obsession death and
glory
in america's most extraordinary treasure
hunt he then released his treasure hunt
to the world
and encouraged anyone and everyone to go
out
and to search for his hidden treasure
but when the poem was first published in
2010
nothing much happened but then a certain
reporter
writing for newsweek magazine wrote a
long piece
about the treasure hunt i think the name
of that reporter
was the same as my name whatever it was
a very hard name to pronounce but i'm
pretty sure it was tony that much i've
got
soon tens of thousands were out there
searching
it really started to raise the profile
of it in a significant way
well i made it hard deliberately if it
was easy anyone could do it
but fenn's game was not without risk
five people died including eric ashby
the only son of paul ashby from
tennessee
forrest fenn was a bad person he could
have stopped this madness
before it became what it became it
wasn't worth it
how does forrest fenn respond to that he
didn't like the idea that anyone would
tell him to bring his hunt to an end
because of a few deaths he said that if
somebody was murdered
because of the hunt that would probably
be too much
tony joins us from his neighborhood
where he's on baby leave as you know
after welcoming me
after welcoming his new daughter eloise
we want to talk about her but first
we'll ask you about this story
hi dad good to see you really good to
see you hey
good morning guys it's lovely to see you
yeah i do not have a beard because i've
been out hunting fenn's treasure
because i'm on daddy leave and i believe
firmly that every child should have a
picture of a young looking dad with a
beard
that's essential to growing up but let
me give you a few words
about the fen about the fence uh mystery
because it is the greatest
adventure and mystery story that i have
ever worked on
and the big question that always comes
up is why didn't he call off the hunt
when people started dying and the answer
is that
fenn would say look i wanted people to
get outdoors
they were and everything has some risk
involved people drown in swimming pools
we don't call off swimming permanently
we teach people how to swim
so he had a kind of a the the the
benefit
outweighs the risk perspective on all of
this now can we talk about eloise
that's what we want to talk about please
number one i love it because i'm over
the moon
oh i love the name it is it's a great
name yeah because it's old-fashioned but
it's also very sweet and really lovely
how did you and katie come up with the
name eloise and did you bring a picture
or two this morning
well it took about three days for us to
come up with the name
she she is waking up by the day by the
second
uh she's she she is uh opening her eyes
she's turning when she hears our voices
she'll grab our fingers she clasps her
hands
i am savoring this gail in such a way
you know i've been here before
yeah it's my fourth child life moves
fast
i can't believe i'm at this point it's
the last time and i'm just soaking up
every moment of it ugh i love it i'm so
in love katie's so in love
she is doing an incredible job
sustaining that child right now as we
speak the babies inside i was going to
do this shoot in my house
uh surrounded by baby debris uh
burping claws and uh sean our our
intrepid executive producer was like
sending me a text message can we please
just do it in a truck where it's gonna
look neat and orderly fine fine
but that's not weird she wants it to
look neat and note to self tony it's not
called baby debris
yet it's called baby accoutrements for
dad's debris
for dads it's a break tony
congratulations speaking of
go ahead thank you thank you i want to
say one more thing that speaking of
baby debris one of her latest tricks is
she can smile
now i am aware that the smile is tied to
baby debris in the diaper
but it is a beautiful and wonderful
thing anyway awesome all right tony
thanks so much you can see
tony's report thanks guys defend
treasure on 48 hours tomorrow night at
10
9 central here on cbs